ajout avec 3 secondes pour autant
grecque
3 si vous vouliez que je revienne
suffisait de me le demander
un appareil qui contrôle tous les
satellites militaires de la planète est
tombé entre les mains de quatre types
près dans son dos on a besoin de
quelqu'un capable de bouger comme moi de
se battre comme el hadji c'est un
patriote
et à plus de patriotes que des rebelles
et des tyrans et vous vous êtes qui moi
je suis triple x je vous présente votre
équipe de soutien tiens voilà le buveur
de red bull
j'ai pas envie d'avoir des tocards pour
me couvrir
alors qu'est ce que vous voulez je veux
du lourd de l'extrême est du
complètement taré
ça c'est une équipe avec laquelle je
peux bosser c'est parti
ça change on sent bien que vous avez
l'expérience système disent tout
après la rumeur ces gens là sont de
vrais tueurs
vous l'avez eu aucune idée de ce que
vous allez affronter je sais pas ce que
tu cherches mais je sais comment calmer
alors je n'aurai pas droit au petit déj
vous lire nous on est prêt à mourir pour
que le monde soit plus tôt
est ce que tu es prêt toi je vis pour ça
on dirait que maintenant on est dans la
même équipe on va s'éclater
je prends bas
c'est pas compliqué
exploser les chocolats filles et essayer
d'avoir l'air cool quand vous le faites
qu'est ce que c'est bon de revenir
ils prétendent que le monde est plus sûr
aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'a jamais été dans
l'histoire de notre civilisation
vous vous vous sentez plus en sécurité
en tout cas moi non
le monde a changé la guerre que nous
menons actuellement
exige un nouveau genre de sanaa
il faut des hommes avec les aptitudes et
la rage nécessaire
pour affronter des menaces que nous
n'envisageons même pas
il nous faut quelqu'un qui peut plonger
dans une tornade et en ressortir comme
s'il ne s'agissait que d'une vulgaire
petit prix si vous vouliez que je
revienne suffisait de me le demander
en clair
défoncez dit
mais ayez l'air cool quand vous le
faites
je sens que je vais m'éclater
des flingues des filles
une domination mondiale zander quel jeu
revient